- For the entrepreneur
who's getting started,
and trying to build this
to a full time business,
or for the entrepreneur
who's already in a full time
and tryin' to get to that next step,
what are some of the tips that you
would give them on how to be productive?
- Well, I often ask my entrepreneurs,
I say, why do you get up and go to bed
in the morning, go to work in the morning?
Why do you get out of bed?
And they say, they think
about it for a while,
and I say, well, the answer is MMM,
which means make more money.
You don't go to work to make less money,
or to make the same money, you go to bed,
you go to work to make more money.
So I say, now how do you make more money?
Well, it's called SMS, and
that means sell more stuff.
And, then, so, you MMM by SMSing.
Now, if you are not selling more stuff
in the course of the day, then
you might was well go home
to bed, covers up over your
head, and go back to sleep,
because you're of no value
to yourself or anyone else.
And then I start to point out,
I notice, I learned this
from a very successful man,
look around your office, all
right, look around your office.
Now, what don't you see in your office?
And the answer is, you don't
see any customers, all right.
So, why are you in your office?
There's no customers there,
you can't sell more stuff,
and if you think you're
going to sell more stuff
by sending out tricky email messages,
then you probably need some medication,
or a check up from the neck up.
The only way that sell
stuff is you go out there
and you talk to customers
and you ask them to buy it.
And, so, if you're not
out asking to buy it.
Now, what are the three
keys to selling more stuff?
They are prospecting,
presenting, and closing.
Prospecting means finding new people
who can and will buy and pay
in a short period of time,
and then telling them, presenting,
that your product or
service, and why it is
the very best choice for them now,
and then closing them, and getting 'em
to make a decision today, this minute.
So, therefore, that all come
together, is prospecting,
presenting and closing is
how you sell more stuff,
which is why you got out
of bed in the first place.
Now, so the interview,
the interesting point
'cause I've been through
all of this myself,
they've interviewed
entrepreneurs, and they say,
"How important are
sales to your business?"
And the entrepreneurs say, "Oh,
most important thing of all.
"Oh, sales, blood to the brain,
"oxygen to the heart, without
that, there's no business."
I say, okay, well, next
question the researchers ask is,
"How much of your time
in the course of the day,
"do you spend selling,
selling more stuff?"
And they say, "Oh, all
day long, that's all I do.
"It's all I think about.
"I get up in the morning,
think about it all day."
And so then they said, "Well, all right,
"do you mind if we follow you around
"with a camera and a
stopwatch for 30 days,
"and just see how you
actually use your time?"
"No problem, no problem at all."
You know what they found out?
The average entrepreneur
spends 11% of their time
prospecting, presenting, and closing.
- [Evan] Well, now.
- The other 89% is spent, excuse
the expression, dicking around.
They're doing fun things, easy things,
checking their email,
checking their email again,
sending out emails, they
are making phone calls,
they're checking their spam,
they are spending so much time.
50% of working time today is wasted.
And, if they're not checking email,
they're chatting with their friends,
and they're chatting with their buddies,
and they're drinking coffee
and they're having lunch,
and they're going around
feeling like big shots
because they've got their own business.
But, the fact of the matter is,
if you're not prospecting,
presenting and closing,
you might as well go home to bed,
because you're of no value, even worse,
you're probably a
detriment to other people
'cause you're stopping them
from working by talking to them,
or sending them email
or keeping them busy.
Email, according to Harvard
University and throughout
three studies I read this
week, is killing entrepreneurs,
'cause they can't stop,
they have this irresistible,
almost like an addiction to
electronic interruptions,
and they can't stop.
And, so, just yesterday,
the Wall Street Journal
had this great article which
is what I've been saying
for the last five years, is turn it off.
Don't turn it down, turn it off.
Check it every two to three
hours, and then turn it off.
"Oh, what if it's an important message?"
Well, what you do is you say this,
I check my email three times a day.
If you've sent me an
email between those times,
I will get back to you as soon as I can.
If this is an emergency,
phone this number.
And the phone will never ring.
And then, what you do, is you
do three 20-minute phases a day.
First of all, your first
check is at 10:30 or 11:00,
you do not check your
email in the morning,
because that immediately addicts you,
and you're on email all day long.
So, you wait 'till 10:30
or 11:00, check it once.
Wait 'till two o'clock, check it again,
wait 'till 4:30, check it the third time.
On and off in 20 minutes and shut it down.
If you can do that, you'll
double and triple your productivity,
and that's one of about a hundred
ideas that I can give you.
But, if you'll just do
that, that'll do more
to help you to be successful
in selling more stuff,
because if you're not wasting
all this time doing that,
you have only one choice
is to sell more stuff,
talk to customers, talk to people
and ask them to buy your product.